dieses video wurde bereits vor einigen
tagen hochgeladen allerdings hatte ich
direkt nach dem upload an probleme mit
dem urheber der hintergrundmusik das
haben jetzt allerdings in den letzten
tagen geklärt und jetzt ja viel spaß bei
dem video
ich hab hunger und was macht man wenn
man hunger hat genau richtig man macht
sich etwas zu essen und dafür gehe ich
jetzt erst mal zu meinem kühlschrank
das ist irgendwie nichts drin außer man
darf natürlich alle wissen dass mich
gibt ist es natürlich auch keine option
jetzt irgendwie 6 liter milch nämlich
rein zu schaufeln deswegen stelle ich
mir jetzt etwas zu essen aber wert wurde
es langweilig wenn ich jetzt einfach auf
der website geht würde wo man sich essen
bestellen kann man ich will mein
lieblings letzte woche noch so zu
stellen wie pizza oder keine ahnung was
sondern ihr dürft das heute mal stimmen
ich befinde mich gerade auf der website
eines lieferdienstes hier in köln und
werde jetzt einfach mal schauen welche
ganzen restaurants in meinem umkreis
eine zu mir essen liefern könne werde
die anzahl dieser restaurants gesagt
lasst es jetzt beispielsweise irgendwie
40 restaurants sein ich werde und jetzt
auf instagram in meiner story sagen hey
leute schickten pdn eine zahl zwischen
141 und dann will ich zufällig eine
person aus die mir irgendeine zahl
zwischen 46 gesagt hat und bei dem
restaurant werde ich bestellen hier 12
16 20 24 28 32 660 64 68 72 2000 jahre
später 144 restaurants liefern in köln
zu einer adresse und ich bestelle mir
jedes mal pizza bei dem gleichen raten
allerdings wie gesagt freuen ich wäre
jetzt ein video und meine instagram
story packen indem ich den leuten sagen
hey scheint mal eine em mit einer zahl
zwischen 1 und 144 also das machen wir
jetzt mal die kamera da ich nehme daten
video auf und wenn ihr bock habt teil
dieses videos zu sein dann schickt mir
jetzt mal per dm eine zahl zwischen 1
und 100 44
ihr habt ihr das video gesehen was ich
meine instagram storage ahorn habe
das sind meine die ems also hier steht
alles irgendwie vor einer minute vor
einer minute jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt wenn ich oben aktualisiere also es
kommen will ich die ganze zeit neue die
ems rheine jetzt ja wird entschieden bei
welchem restaurant ich meine es und
bestellen werde also dass hier sind die
die ms gerade freunde das sind alles
leute die mir gerade irgendwelche zahlen
geschickt haben das heißt ich mache
jetzt die augen zu und drückte jetzt
einfach ich gehe noch mal ganz kurz nach
oben jetzt wirklich einfach irgendwo
stoppt diese personen hier ihr seht ich
bin genau auf diesen namen
ich gehe jetzt mit dem namen runter und
wir haben diese zahl 73 ich werde bei
restaurant 73 bestellen
73 das hier ist restaurant nummer 73
freunde ich bin halt immer so viele
schritte runter gegangen aber das hier
ist restaurant x 73 little india und wir
haben ja als essens beschreibung
angegeben scharf bericht die
bestellseite jetzt hier raus also wir
haben hier die ganzen sechs und salate
dann haben wir hier von dori
spezialitäten dann haben wir schicken
spezialitäten also die haben wirklich
unmengen an spalten und das hier vorne
sind halt die verschiedenen kategorien
essen als wenn wir beispielsweise lahm
wir haben schicken wie gesagt haben
vegetarische spezialitäten und jetzt
werde ich meinen die halte ich kann die
kamera bei dem restaurant little india
existieren elf verschiedene
kategorien sage ich mal an essen also
hier beispielsweise die sehr nahen
freund spezialitäten reich spezialitäten
wie vorhin gesagt vegetarische land
schicken dass alles bei vorhandener seid
jetzt dürfen die leute eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 11 sagen jetzt ist eure
aufgabe mir per dm eine zahl zwischen 1
und 11 zu senden
also los wir sind wieder die ems von
allen leuten die mir jetzt gerade eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 11 geschickt haben
dass ich mal wieder meine augen zu
scrollen bisschen hoch und runter ein
bisschen vor zurück war blablabla
freunde und die sache hier
diese person mein finger drauf ihr seht
die zahl ihr seht die zahl freunde da
recht eingeblendet wird sie 18
kategorien nummer acht dort werde ich
jetzt schauen welches nicht mehr
bestellen also nummer eins in snacks und
salate zwei suppen 3456 vegetarische 678
reis spezialitäten
ich dachte erst als die laden gesehen
habe video little india scharfes essen
vegetarisch ich bin voll am arsch aber
reist könnte nice 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14
freunde little india hat 14 verschiedene
reisgerichte allerdings großen hunger
habe werde ich jetzt meinen leuten auch
instagram sagen hey schreibt mir zwei
zahlen zwischen 1 und 14
hey ich schon wieder letzte sache
schreibt mir jetzt zwei zahlen zwischen
1 und 14
ja dann sind wir fertig hier vorne mal
wieder die ems freunde er mich aktuell
immer wieder dass wir die noch mehr drin
haben wir mit sucker mal wieder runter
macht die augen zu sky wieder hoch bis
zum runter bisschen hoch und hier
diese person grün gehen becky hat mir
elf und neun geschrieben sieht man dass
mein fokus leider ein bisschen kaputt
aber ich glaube das kann man erkennen 11
und 19 wieder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 das
erste was ich mir vorstelle werde es
zwei teigtaschen auf eine wiese dazu
hausgemachter dip also das kommt rein in
den warenkorb und dann haben wir als
nächstes was mir noch bestellen werde
chicken tikka salat mariniert das
hähnchenfleisch mit einem frischen salat
das sind jetzt zwölf euro 30 und ich
glaube nicht dass ich davon satt werde
aber gut der zufall hat entschied sich
instagram hat entschieden aber das ist
ja eigentlich auch wieder zufall
dankeschön wir haben eine bestellung
bekommen geschätzte ankunftszeit 34
minuten
wir warten jetzt halbe stunde und dann
wird ein echtes lieferanten wir meinen
von euch ausgesucht das essen bringen
ich bin gespannt weil sowas hätte ich
niemals bestellt während wir jetzt hier
allerdings 34 minuten warten des ist da
vorne an der tür klingelt meine damen
und herren habe ich ja schon in einem
der letzten videos gesagt dass ich
demnächst mal ein paar neue sachen von
meinem virgin des vorstellen wäre was am
ersten sechs in den am ersten sechs
kommen nämlich fünf neue merchandise
produkte in meinen shop und zwei frische
produkte von den zwei special produkten
habe ich bisher schon eine jeansjacke
in einem der letzten videos vorgestellt
die ist allerdings gerade zurück in
italien weil die hat im schnitt nach
bauen müssen und was ich euch auch noch
gezeigt habe ist dieser overtime stone
washed rudi mit diesem look through
stieg hier vorne drin war es sich
handschriftlich darauf geschrieben habe
also nicht auf dem pulli geschrieben ist
das papier geschrieben dass eingescannt
draufgepackt nachgezeichnet eingesteckt
was ich euch allerdings bisher nur auf
irgendwelchen videos in meiner story
oder so gezeigt habe ist dieses shirt
steht vorne erst mal nur lcr w drauf
also luke ruhe ohne die vokale
das ist von vorne relativ klein gehalten
und schlecht gehalten allerdings von
hinten
wie findet ihr den freund servus dafür
eine neue variante entschieden also
nicht das noch mal drauf gedruckt aber
das werdet ihr dann schon sehen wenn ihr
das in den händen halten falls ihr euch
das bestellen solltet also soll vom
vortag war sie einfach nur wenn man sich
das normal laufen wird und einfach ein
symbol iran hat sich dann einfach nur
lcr von hinten dann allerdings und
fetter print mit allen sachen für die
ich irgendwie ein bisschen stehe also lc
rwe um darüber quasi die luchse also
ihrem eine community haben dann haben
wir so eine explosion wurde ein song
smile in der mitte ist weil es mein logo
ist und jeweils mit no go ist dann haben
wir hier vorne und einpacken gezeichnet
weil es einfach meine lieblingstiere
sind hier vorne haben wir die tester die
da vorne drin als mbh mir auch ab und zu
ein paar das sieht man jetzt nicht ganz
genau weil so ein paar musiknoten weil
die schmucke über alles feier und
eventuell auch demnächst meine eigenen
mixtapes hier auf youtube hochladen
werde das habe ich das denn der sound
gemacht aber ich wollte das jetzt auch
mal mit video und so auf youtube machen
also neben dem stonewall studie mit
dieser
anschrift lucio hier anhalt stieg und
der jeansjacke die grad in italien ist
wird auch noch dieses t shirt hier in
den shop kommen was wie gesagt von vorne
relativ simpel gehalten von hinten an
dieser band mit allen sachen für die
stehe und freunde habe ich noch gar
nicht richtig darüber geredet der
komplette shop wird ein neues design
bekommen es ist alles noch mal viel viel
kleiner
viele leute sagen mir hey luca das ist
doch gar keine richtige website so voll
viele haben doch irgendwie so lisa und
lena die haben da noch ihre beiträge und
block und verlinkungen ich möchte
einfach nur dass der lukas shop das sind
die produkte alles ist schön klinsmann
weiß direkt woran man ist sehen viele
leute anders allerdings möchte ich dass
das wirklich einfach simple klein
gehalten wird einfach meinen job
wir werden eine neue shop system
aufsetzen wenn jetzt mal gent o2 das ist
das krasseste shopsystem was man haben
kann also wenn leute das hacken wollen
oder wenn wir wieder millionen zugriffe
pro stunde haben dann ist alles
abgesichert diesmal allerdings will ich
hier gar nicht mehr lange bei meinem
merchandise lagern freunde natürlich ist
es mein kanal und das ist mir es liegt
mir sehr am herzen und ich habe da sehr
viel spaß daran die sachen zu design
allerdings soll es heute darum gehen
dass der zufall mein essen bestimmt und
das essen ist in zehn minuten da es ist
da
ja
danke also das hier ist das essen was
wir jetzt gestellt haben wo bin ich ein
spaß die eltern ja ich habe jetzt hier
versucht sind irgendeiner form
appetitlich anzurichten aber es sieht
echt chaos also das hier ist dieses
kleine ahnung was dargestellt habe und
dass jetzt in der bin laden die ganzen
hähnchen stücke schon in der tüte
verteilt waren allerdings machen wir
jetzt mal geschmackstest also ihr
dürftet ihr entscheiden in welchem
restaurant ich bestelle und welche
speicher ist bestellen soll deswegen
haben
der salat an sich ist aber eigentlich
recht lecker
jetzt gehe ich mal das andere ich weiß
nicht was das ist ich weiß dass das für
komischen vögeln tierchen hier drinnen
sind aber kaum noch viel schärfer
ich hasse scharfes essen an der stelle
mich dass wir jetzt allerdings verfällt
meine damen und herren die inspiration
für dieses video haben von puky der das
video hochgeladen also checkt gärtner
aus dass auch so ähnlich gemacht wenn
euch dieses video hier gefallen hat und
ihr euch eventuell denken lokal stell
doch mal da irgendwie zu verlieren und
er ist ja nicht zufällig bestellt aber
falls ihr den habe was nicht wenn du das
nächste mal machen sollen was so ähnlich
in die richtung geht schreibt für gerne
die kommentare schaffen wir 50.000 live
und ist eine große zahl für mega freuen
und sonst bin ich an der stelle einfach
nur noch sagen
kleiner nachtrag ich hab jetzt nachdem
ich das video beendet haben natürlich
noch mein essen auch gegessen was ich
mir bestellt habe und ich weiß nicht ob
man sieht und an meinen augen ich bin
gerade der teufel das essen war ohne
scheiß so unfassbar schaaf weiß es gibt
leute die feiern das essen so mega denn
das ultra schaffst aber ich verstehe
schärfe nicht warum bestellt man etwas
scharfes s bedrängt einem doch nur
schmerzen
[Applaus]
das wollte ich noch mal gesagt haben